This video was made possible by Hover.
Professionalize your web presence with a custom
domain and email address for 10% off at hover.com/Wendover.
About 13 million times per day, someone clicks
the order button on amazon.com.
Some days later, all, or at least almost all,
of those 13 million orders arrive at their
destination.
But what happens in between?
How does Amazon get a package to you?
Well, it depends… a lot.
In fact, Amazon’s fulfillment system, their
shipping system, is more complicated and convoluted
than that of almost any logistics company.
It’s far more complicated than that of UPS,
or FedEx, or DHL, or any other major delivery
company.
In a counterintuitive way, this complicated
and convoluted fulfillment system is a crucial
component of the secret sauce that’s driving
Amazon’s success.
They’re striving to make the consumer experience
simple through behind-the-scenes complexity.
So, back to the question: how does an Amazon
package get to you, and the answer, it depends.
It depends first on who’s fulfilling the
package—Amazon or the seller.
About one fourth of sales in the US are fulfilled
directly by the seller, as most products on
Amazon are listed there by a third-party,
which can send packages directly through UPS,
FedEx, the postal service, or another consumer
delivery company if they choose.
Amazon has nothing to do with the fulfillment
of those orders, and the process looks largely
the same as with any other e-commerce company.
What’s different is how the other three
quarters of Amazon packages in the US get
to you—the ones that are fulfilled directly
by Amazon.
The path that these take depends first on
how big the package is.
You see, Amazon’s fulfillment centers are
more-or-less split into three categories:
small sortable, large sortable, and large
non-sortable.
That first category, small sortable, represents
the bread and butter of Amazon’s business.
These are items that are less than 12 by 16
by 6 inches or 30 by 40 by 15 centimeters
in size, and about 25 pounds or 11 kilograms
in weight.
The next category, large sortable, is basically
anything larger than this up to a weight of
about 60 pounds or 27 kilograms.
Now, the reason for the split between large
and small is because the fulfillment operations
of smaller items is much easier to automate—they
can fit on conveyor belts and automated robots
and other tools that lower the company's reliance
on humans.
For example, Amazon uses a robot called the
Kiva which fundamentally changed the way the
job of the company’s pickers, the people
who find and grab an item out of storage,
worked.
Previously, pickers would walk some 10 to
12 miles or 16 to 19 kilometers a day through
cavernous rows of shelves.
Now, at least in their most advanced fulfillment
centers, a robot picks up an entire mobile
shelf, on which a required product is located,
and transports it to the picker, who picks
it.
Essentially, rather than the picker going
to the shelf, the shelf goes to the picker.
With these robots, one person can pick three
to four hundred items an hour rather than
the one hundred or so that was possible on
foot.
Of course, fewer humans in the mix is good
for Amazon, given the amount of criticism
it receives for its treatment of workers,
and also because humans, even low-paid ones,
are expensive.
The fulfillment process for larger items,
though, is just tougher to automate cheaply,
so the company chooses to segment the two
processes out, and runs a far more manual
and distinct fulfillment system for larger
items.
However, in most, but not all cases, the fulfillment
centers for large and small items are under
the same roof, even if they’re operated
completely independently.
Of course, the ideal scenario for Amazon would
be to have every single item they sell in
every single warehouse, but that’s not realistic.
Therefore, they use predictive modeling to
try to put items closest to those who are
likely to buy them.
The US is far from homogeneous, so demand
for different products varies from place to
place.
For example, in Miami, people probably aren’t
looking to buy many ice scrapers for their
cars.
Meanwhile, in Fargo, North Dakota, demand
for this item is almost certainly quite high.
It’s therefore no wonder why that, if you
look at the data, the colder the city, the
faster you can get an ice scraper on Amazon.
That is Amazon’s predictive stocking at
work.
While most examples of this system are far
more nuanced and far less intuitive, the concept
is simple: their algorithms put products closest
to the consumers most likely to buy them—something
only possible at this scale thanks to modern
big-data analytics.
Of course, there’s then that third category
of products—large non-sortable.
The distinction here is because Amazon likes
to aggregate products together into as few
packages as possible—unsurprisingly, fewer
packages equals lower costs.
So, both the sortable categories include anything
that could possibly be packaged together in
a single box.
The largest items—say a 70 pound beanbag,
for example—are shipped from the large non-sortable
fulfillment centers.
These facilities are even less automated than
the large-sortable ones, and even include
workers who create custom boxes for odd-sized
items.
In Colorado, for example, this is a completely
separate facility, located in Aurora, from
the sortable fulfillment center in Thornton.
Now, some large items will go directly into
the system of a third-party provider, typically
XPO Logistics, which would deliver these bulky
items to their final destination, while others
will continue on in Amazon’s system.
The portion of large non-sortable items not
sent to a third party logistics provider,
plus all the large and small sortable packages
would next be sent to a regional sortation
center.
In Colorado, those two fulfillment centers
send their packages to a single sortation
center, located just minutes away from the
Aurora fulfillment center.
This is a massive facility, almost half a
million square feet in size, with robots running
around, dropping packages into different chutes,
which each represent a different grouping
of zip codes.
Now, not all the sortation centers are quite
so automated, but each outputs the same thing—pallets
of packages going to roughly the same place.
What happens next, though, once again, depends.
A package heading to Miami, for example, would
end up on a pallet with other packages for
Miami, which itself would end up on a truck
carrying pallets for Tampa, North Carolina,
Houston, Baltimore, New York City, Connecticut
and a few other cities and states to the east.
This truck would then drive the 15 minutes
to a waiting 767 cargo plane at Denver International
Airport branded in “Prime Air” livery.
Now, Amazon Air started in 2015 with its lease
of about 20 aircraft from Air Transport International
and has since grown to almost 70 aircraft—all
leased from other airlines.
However, the company recently announced the
purchase of their first 11 aircraft—also
767, bought from Delta and WestJet—meaning
they’ll soon both own and operate their
own aircraft.
Those eastbound pallets would all be loaded
around 4:00 am, before the aircraft’s scheduled
departure time of 4:54 am.
Now, anyone familiar with UPS or FedEx’s
operations will know why this departure time
is strange.
If UPS was transporting this package to Miami,
at least at its fastest speed, it would have
departed on an aircraft the previous night
at 9:40 pm, been flown to Louisville, sorted
through the company’s hub, then flown to
Miami, arriving at 5:50 am.
FedEx would have done roughly the same, just
through Memphis instead.
That’s because FedEx, UPS, and most other
major delivery companies are oriented towards
overnight delivery—they make a big chunk
of their money charging big rates to take
a package from one part of the US one day
and deliver it to another the next day.
Amazon, meanwhile, built their Prime brand
off of the promise of two-day delivery—ordering
a package on a Monday and getting it on a
Wednesday, for example.
While they’ve since strayed from the rigidness
of that system, the fastest shipping they’ll
offer for an item not stocked at a local fulfillment
center is two days, meaning they don’t have
to worry about being able to get a package
from Denver to Miami overnight.
That’s why UPS and FedEx’s planes take
off in the evening, while Amazon’s leave
in the morning.
So, that means it’s about 9:00 am by the
time that Amazon Air plane from Denver gets
to Cincinnati airport each day.
Through the morning hours, a dozen or so aircraft
land in Cincinnati, and this timing gives
the company a major advantage.
Cincinnati airport is also home to DHL’s
main Americas hub, but DHL, like FedEx and
UPS, conducts its operations primarily overnight
starting at around midnight, when dozens of
their aircraft from all around the world land
and unload.
Over the next few hours, packages and pallets
are sorted and loaded onto other aircraft,
which all tend to take off by 8:00 am.
That means DHL only really uses their facility
during the overnight hours, so Amazon leases
it for daytime use.
While Amazon is building their own, larger
facility at Cincinnati airport, this partnership
gave them a huge head-start.
So, each day, between 8:00 am and 4:00 pm,
Amazon’s there, turning their planes around,
and sorting pallets from where they come from,
like Denver, to where they need to go, like
Miami.
That Miami flight takes off each weekday at
2:15 pm, and then it lands in Florida just
before 5:00 pm eastern time.
Now, not every Amazon Air itinerary looks
like this.
In fact, while UPS and FedEx route almost
all of their flights through their Louisville
and Memphis super-hubs, or through some of
their secondary hubs across the country, only
20% of Amazon Air’s flights go through their
main Cincinnati hub.
That’s because, with the orientation towards
two-day delivery versus one, they just have
more time.
The more time means that, in order to service
the entirety of Florida, Amazon only needs
to fly to three destinations—Miami, Tampa,
and and Lakeland.
That’s because Amazon’s flights to these
airports typically land by 5:00 pm, meaning
there’s a whole twelve hours before packages
have to be at the local delivery center for
the final destination.
The entirety of Florida is within an eight-hour
drive of Lakeland, meaning Amazon can deliver
to all of Florida by only serving effectively
one, but in practice three airports.
Meanwhile, FedEx, for example, flies from
Memphis to Fort Lauderdale, Fort Myers, Jacksonville,
Tallahassee, Tampa, and Palm Beach, then,
from Fort Lauderdale, it operates feeder flights
on smaller aircraft to Key West and Marathon.
So, in summary, in order to serve all of Florida,
this is what FedEx has to do and this is what
Amazon has to do.
The required number of destinations for full
coverage is greatly reduced by orienting for
two-day delivery, and this also means that
Amazon doesn’t have to route every flight
via one main hub.
Because they operate to far fewer destinations,
it’s much easier for Amazon to fill a plane
from California, for example, exclusively
with packages destined for Florida, since
while a given UPS or FedEx flight carries
packages from or to just one city, a given
Amazon Air flight likely carries packages
from or to a whole state or region.
Therefore, Amazon Air has flights from all
these airports to Lakeland, meaning that,
while a package from Denver would have to
route via Cincinnati, one from Los Angeles
or Dallas or Chicago could fly direct.
With a full hub-and-spoke strategy, like that
of UPS or FedEx, a package would have to be
loaded and unloaded from aircraft twice, and
sometimes more, while Amazon Air’s nonstop
flights only require loading and unloading
once, which reduces cost, and can fly packages
direct, which also reduces cost.
This is how Amazon can transport packages
by air more efficiently than UPS or FedEx.
The airplane, however, is just one of five
routes that an Amazon package could take onwards
from the Denver sortation center.
For those that are to be delivered locally,
in the Denver area, they’ll be driven to
one of four delivery stations for Denver.
There, they’ll be loaded into smaller delivery
vans, operated by independent companies or
individuals contracted by Amazon, which will
take the packages to their final destinations.
This is the one and only case in which an
Amazon package is handled by Amazon logistics
from start to finish, and it’s generally
how their packages are delivered within major
urban and suburban areas.
Only a slim majority of their overall package
volume is delivered this way, though, as when
you leave major urban areas, things get a
bit more complicated.
Now, a package heading outside the Denver
area with a later delivery date, or with a
destination within the greater Rockies region,
would end up on an Amazon-branded, but independently
operated semi-truck.
For example, packages to the Aspen area, about
a three to four hour drive into the mountains,
leave at around 1:00 am each night.
Early in the morning, however, at around 5:00
am, they arrive at the local post office and
from there, they’re fully transferred into
the United States Postal Service system for
final delivery.
You see, in less populous areas, like the
mountains of Colorado, it just doesn’t make
sense for Amazon to operate their own last-mile
delivery.
They need a certain amount of scale for that
to be cheaper than the alternative, and, at
least right now, that scale is only possible
in major metro areas.
Therefore, they need alternatives for smaller
cities, towns, and rural areas, and that alternative
is more often than not the USPS.
That’s because the postal service charges
very low rates for last-mile delivery, assuming
Amazon transports the packages to the local
post office themselves.
While exact numbers aren’t publicly known,
estimates indicate the USPS charges Amazon
about $2 per package for last-mile delivery—about
half of what other delivery companies would
for the same service.
After all, the USPS services every address
in America, so wherever Amazon needs to deliver,
the USPS is going there anyways.
That’s why for smaller places that still
have a decent volume of packages, like mid-sized
towns and cities, USPS delivery is often the
cheapest option for Amazon.
But then there’s that next step down—the
most rural places in America.
Everything that can’t be cheaply delivered
by Amazon or the USPS, typically because they’re
destined for low-density areas where you couldn’t
even fill a truck to send to the local post
office, or because of capacity or speed reasons,
is sent through UPS.
Right now, it’s believed that about 20%
of Amazon’s packages end up delivered by
UPS.
In Colorado, a package destined for the most
rural areas, like the western edge of San
Miguel County, for example, would take this
route.
It would cost Amazon far more, and they’d
likely end up losing money on the cheapest
items, but it’s what’s required for them
to be able to service every address in the
US quickly.
No matter which of these routes a package
takes, the end result is, at least hopefully,
the same—UPS, the USPS, or Amazon itself
drops off a package at its final destination,
after a few days of travel across the US.
It’s a very simple process from a consumer
perspective, but the behind the scenes is
incredibly complex.
The complexity is what’s needed, though,
for a business who’s whole value proposition
is to get anything to your door quickly and
cheaply.
The core of Amazon, their competitive advantage,
is now logistics, to the point where many
experts believe that the company will start
offering delivery as a service to other companies
in the coming years.
They believe that they’ve perfected their
system enough that they’re going to take
on UPS and FedEx.
Of course, Amazon still has competitors, which
are going after the company as aggressively
as ever.
Target, for example, has been able to build
a delivery system with similar speed through
completely different means—ones that are
far simpler.
They’ve essentially turned each of their
1,900 stores across every US state into a
fulfillment center.
They send employees out into the aisles who
pick, pack, and ship online orders.
That means that their packages never have
to travel very far at all, and so they can
take advantage of cheap and quick ground shipping
from UPS, FedEx, and other more traditional
providers.
Some 80% of the company’s orders are fulfilled
directly from its stores and now Walmart is
also adopting this direct-from-store fulfillment
system as well.
So far, though, Amazon believes in their system
of simplicity through complexity, and they’re
making moves to further expand the system
within the US and emulate it in Europe, where
they recently opened their first air hub in
Leipzig, and put their first two freight aircraft
online in November, 2020.
UPS, FedEx, and the other major consumer delivery
companies are already well aware of just how
big a threat Amazon poses to them.
Amazon has managed to build a 21st-century
logistics network using 21st-century techniques
and technologies, and, of course, part of
the threat comes from the company’s market
dominance, but most is because Amazon is innovating
in a way others aren’t.
The way FedEx and UPS move packages today
is largely the same way they did decades ago,
but Amazon’s system is only possible through
innovations that allow them to manage such
a massive, complex, and convoluted system.
This is all to say: if you’re worried about
Amazon’s growing position as the one-stop-shop
for the world, be worried, because they’re
only getting better at it.
What Amazon’s rise proves more than anything
is that, like it or not, online is the new
main street.
Therefore, just as you’d be concerned with
what your store-front looks like on main street,
you should be concerned about how your web
presence looks.
Now, in the case of email, having a non-custom
address is the equivalent of having a dirty
sign—it works, but it’s not pretty.
That’s why you’ll notice that most professionals
use custom email addresses—something that
ends in something like @wendover.productions.
That’s a domain that I bought through Hover,
made possible thanks to their over 400 unique
domain extensions that let you go way behind
.com, .org, or .net.
After getting that domain, it took about two
minutes to set up a custom email address for
myself and everyone else who works on the
channel.
I can’t count the number of times when someone
has complimented our email addresses, as weird
as that sounds, and so whether you run a business,
or just want a better email for yourself,
it’s worth getting a custom one with Hover.
So, head to hover.com/Wendover to get 10%
off your first purchase of a custom domain
or email address, and you’ll be supporting
the channel while you’re at it.